well Kenya's president-elect William
Bruto is again calling for Unity and
says he's ready to get down to the
business of governing he's held a media
conference in which he said people have
chosen their leaders Kenya's electoral
commission gave fruto 50.4 percent of
the vote but his opponent raila odinga
is disputing the result saying he will
challenge it in court
on TV screens
people from all corners of Kenya
saying we listened to you guys
we want to know when the delivery of
your commitment is going to begin
and and I really want us to know that
the expectations of the people of Kenya
is huge and therefore we do not have the
luxury of wasting any time
okay we're going to go live now to
Malcolm Webb who is in Nairobi and has
been covering this election
William Russo didn't mention oh doing it
by name it all in his address and he
spoke directly to the Kenyan people
about unifying the country do you think
he'll be able to do that though
well yeah he was talking mostly about
what they want to do when uh if and when
they take uh office but he was very much
talking about when speaking with a lot
of confidence that that would happen but
it was on Tuesday afternoon that raila
odinga rejected those results and said
that him and his Coalition would do
everything they could legally and
constitutionally to get those results
overturned now the Constitution gives
petitioners seven days after the
announcement of results so there are
just five days left to file a petition
to the Supreme Court so we're waiting to
find out if raila odinga's zimeo
Coalition or if other rights groups will
file uh petitions and it can be expected
at this stage for at least any
politically motivated petitioners to
keep their cards close to their chest
when this happened last time five years
ago following the election then raila
odinga was at the time leading the
opposition he challenged the election
result in court that petition was
submitted did right at the last hour
before that deadline was met that's
likely so that lawyers are given maximum
time to gather evidence and minimum time
for any respondents to prepare so we'll
be watching over the next few days to
see if anyone will be filing a petition
up to that deadline which will come on
Monday
how come we heard very early on from the
Independent election observers that this
was a fair election but what weight has
been given to that and have they
responded at all to odinga's claims
uh the election observers is a coalition
of observers of rights groups and
faith-based organizations uh here in
Kenya what they excuse me they took a
sample of a thousand polling stations
and the data from those polling stations
matched within a margin of error the
data uh published by the Electoral
commission so what they were saying is
that that shows that the tallying and
the counting uh had been according to
their data uh you know well it matched
it matched the sample that they had
taken uh there would be another
complaints at earlier stages about
problems with the Electoral register uh
some oppositions or sorry raila odinga
supporters on there on social media I've
been alleging other kinds of
irregularities but we're not really
getting any details from uh azimio
railroadinger's Coalition or anyone else
about what those irregularities might be
and uh if they might constitute part of
a petition that is submitted to the
Supreme Court
Malcolm Webb in Nairobi for us thank you